kelly clarkson still fangirling over
everyone she met at the Golden Globes
how Meryl Streep really felt about
Mariah Carey stealing her seat [ __ ]
stole my everybody how we holdin up I am
like on day three of my work week and
it's only Tuesday also I'm an idiot I'm
doing a 3 day detox which we've no
coffee which means I'm not well so we
just wrapped up the Golden Globes and if
you watch our live recap yesterday then
you know that Mariah Carey apparently
stole meryl streep seat during the show
while Meryl got a little sassy about the
snafu sharing her side of the story on
Jimmy Kimmel last night [ __ ] stole my
knocked him over and there she was you
know next to Spielberg sucking up I see
she said oh my god they made me sit down
because you know we're moving
they make you you know they say five
four three two one wherever you are
everybody has to drop to their you know
it's like musical chairs in a way I kind
of in we left out I was but I said no no
stay there and I said I'll sit on your
lap because you know all right I need
Mariah to sample Meryl saying [ __ ]
stole my seat into her next single he
was saying well listen Mariah wasn't the
only star at the Golden Globes to have a
chance run-in with Queen Meryl in fact
Kelly Clarkson is still shook by meeting
the Oscar winner she ran home with her
gown still on and told fans all about it
on her new web series minute and a glass
of wine I don't know if you noticed if
you watch the building below say but
this cheek has been caressed by Meryl
Streep Oh
[Music]
that's right it's fine it's not a big
deal I'm not even sure she knew who I
was she was really nice regardless which
makes her like an even more amazing
person because she'd just be nice to
anyone and my husband could hear and
talking with all the people like while
we were waiting and he said that she was
very lovely now that's cool but Kelly
also got to finally meet someone 12
years in the making
Steve Carell who gave her a literal
shout-out in 40 year old virgin remember
the one Kelly Clarkson okay even though
Kelly has always wanted to meet Steve it
never happened until Sunday's Golden
Globes Steve tweeted a pic of them
together writing finally and I think
it's safe to say it's one of Kelly's
favorite moments in her life - I will
say another amazing moment tonight was
that I got to meet Steve Carell why
because that's what they do at the
Golden Globes but anyway I got to meet
Steve and he was so awesome and his wife
and I love when you meet people you love
and they're so lovely Kelly meeting
famous people is all of us meeting
famous people all right now the question
on everybody's mind out of the Golden
Globes is Oprah ready to make a run for
the White House I've truly watched
Oprah's speech at least five times now
and it still got everybody fired up
including Stephen Colbert who gave us a
glimpse of what an Oprah presidency
would look like we did ever go toe to
toe with North Korea I believe she could
come kim jong-un down just by helping
him lose weight it's a point system
it's all points right Touche Touche
Colbert but will Oprah 2020 actually
happen if there was one person close to
Oprah who knows it's Gayle King and only
eats he spoke to Gail today in New York
do think she is intrigued that doesn't
mean that she's thinking about running
but I do think that that speech was a
different moment for her I think that it
was she and she knew that she met the
moment but the reaction to the speech I
think has been sort of overwhelming to
her I do believe that but I do think
she's intrigued by it but listen Oprah's
got a very nice light she's doing very
well for herself and it's not like this
is not something that she is seeking or
trying to encourage people to even
encourage her to run you heard it from
Gail folks but Never Say Never
I what do you guys think is it too
far-fetched or could you see Oprah in
the White House let me know all right
you guys I'm gonna get out of here I
think we're running a little short and I
apologize because I'm gonna faint I love
you like and share this video I'll see
you guys tomorrow
I'm on